la endometriosis es una condición en la
que un tejido similar al revestimiento
del útero crece en otras áreas del
cuerpo si es mujer su sistema
reproductor incluye la vagina
el útero
las trompas de falopio y los ovarios
durante el ciclo de menstruación normal
los ovarios producen químicos
denominados hormonas
que le dan la orden al revestimiento del
útero para que se espese el
revestimiento denominado endometrio se
espesa para prepararse para recibir al
óvulo fertilizado si el óvulo no se
fertiliza el útero elimina el
revestimiento a través de la vagina este
sangrado mensual se denomina el periodo
de menstruación
si tiene endometriosis crece tejido
similar al revestimiento fuera del útero
por razones que no son claras el tejido
fuera del lugar responde a las hormonas
igual que si estuviera dentro del útero
este tejido continúa expresándose y
luego se elimina con el sangrado en cada
ciclo menstrual sin embargo la sangre y
el tejido que se eliminan fuera del
útero no tienen forma alguna de salir
del cuerpo
el flujo endometrial atrapado puede
filtrarse en las áreas circundantes y
así causar inflamación y dolor
es posible que se formen bandas de
tejido de cicatriz denominadas
adherencias las cuales pegan los órganos
entre sí o hacen que se cierren las
trompas de falopio esto puede afectar su
fertilidad que es la capacidad para
quedar embarazada la endometriosis puede
formar endometrio más también conocidos
como quistes de chocolate estos quistes
son sacos llenos de fluido en los
ovarios que pueden afectar la fertilidad
la endometriosis también puede ocasionar
una hemorragia anormal
los sitios más comunes donde se produce
la endometriosis son los ovarios las
trompas de falopio la parte exterior del
útero las estructuras que contienen al
útero y que están a su alrededor y el
revestimiento de la pelvis denominado
peritoneo otros sitios incluyen la
vejiga
el recto y los intestinos
si padece de endometriosis es posible
que tenga uno o más de los siguientes
síntomas dolor de pelvis central crónico
y generalmente en aumento
dolor antes o durante la menstruación
dolor durante el sexo que se siente bien
profundo en la pelvis dolor al orinar
durante la menstruación movimientos
intestinales dolorosos durante la
menstruación hemorragia normal diarrea
estreñimiento náuseas y dificultad para
quedar embarazada denominada
infertilidad
es posible que su médico le recomiende
opciones de tratamientos de las
siguientes categorías
y medicamentos para el tratamiento del
dolor como aspirina acetaminofeno o
medicamentos antiinflamatorios sin
esteroides conocidos como ns aid que
alivian el dolor
la terapia de hormonas como pastillas
anticonceptivas puede prevenir la
acumulación endometrial y la hemorragia
mensuales
es posible que necesite un procedimiento
quirúrgico para tratar el tejido que
causa dolor o hemorragia los tipos de
procedimiento incluyen retiro
destrucción del tejido endometrial
retiro de adherencias y tejido de
cicatriz
retiro o drenaje de los quistes
retiro destrucción de las fibras
nerviosas que transmiten dolor
retiro del útero denominado
histerectomía
o retiro de los ovarios denominado o
forec tome a